You're listening to radio
lab from public radio, w.N y.
S t engine, n. P. R. What
we have over the criminal.
The criminal actually thinks he's
destroyed. It will be evidence
[inaudible]
ever, ever, ever. Never.
This is Lou Garcia originally retired
from the New York city fire department as
the chief fire Marshall,
so I've spent 25 years of my life looking
at fires and investigating the causes
of fire. How many fires do
you think you've seen? Oh,
tens of thousands of fires.
You've seen 10 years of
[inaudible] yourself. Yeah.
When he tells me his story
there was this a true story?
I'm not going to get too
many details about it,
but there was a fire in an area of
New York City who was in an apartment
building in the south Bronx. As
I pulled up to this building,
the fire was already over with Lou Gatto.
There were people in the street and we're
questioning people. People are saying,
well, in the apartment where the
fire was, it was this brave guy.
Somehow he'd gotten in there and
he was pouring water on fire,
trying to get the fire out. This guy
was really something and he's, and he's,
he's a hero right now. Everybody's
telling me what a hero he is. Everything.
The thing that we're saying in the
street about this man was wrong.
[inaudible]
so he walks into the apartment,
he looks around and he knows right away
where the fire started. Now how, why,
how, well, you just
look at the fire pattern
and could tell that the fire started first
of all in the bedroom with a mattress
mattress. The mattress now matches go
up. If you put a match to it. Really?
I mean, don't you have to put like
gasoline on the mattress? No, no, no.
Let me just put a match onto a match
mattress and it will catch fire. Yes.
If you hold that one off. Yeah.
And he also knew that the mattress had
been placed upright against the wall.
You could tell by the fire pattern
that was standing on it. Wow.
He can even know what position
the mattress was in. Yes,
absolutely. Believe me.
So he meets the woman whose apartment
this is, she shows up and he says this,
so do you know this fellow who was
putting out the fire? She was, yes.
As a matter of fact, I do. Just so
happens that you used to live with me,
but I kicked him out. He
still had a key by the way,
and she knows, says I
have a new boyfriend,
so Garcia naturally
goes and finds the hero,
so now I'm questioning this fall. I said,
by the way, did you buy that mattress?
And he said, yes I did.
And you weren't sleeping anymore with
someone else who'd been on the mattress in
your place? And he says, yeah, we
should have the boyfriend. I said, boy,
I'd be pissed. How much did the question?
Like four or $500 you said no more
than that. It was like 800 off. I said,
so now she is screwing somebody
else on the mattress you bought.
I would be pissed. I said, you know,
if it was me, if I were in your place,
I would want this mattress in the
barn. I was probably standard on end.
I would take matches, matches, and I
would put it to the, to the mattress.
That's what I would do. And in fact,
I'm an expert on fires and I know that's
what you did. You really did do that.
Yeah, you can talk about
it. I don't blame you.
I mean at least you tried to put it out,
but they'll work in your favor and
court and he looks at me. He says, well,
you're not so smart. I said,
wine. He goes, I used the lighter
[inaudible].
Oh, you're right about that.
Okay, so that was an easy one. We're
going to have some harder ones coming up.
Yup. Point is the whole hour. We're
going to be addressing the same problem.
We'll walk into one situation after
another and discover that something is not
right here. That's right. It's something's
not right with my son. What do I do?
Something's not right with
my pancreas. What do I do?
Something's not right with the very
phrase something is not right because it
presumes that I know what's right and
maybe I don't have we confused you enough?
Well, there's a whole lot of abnormal
things coming your way. This is Radiolab.
I'm Jad Abumrad and I'm
Robert Quilt. Stay with us.
Okay.
Okay. So this first story is about, uh,
delivering a diagnosis comes to us
from producer Louisville, Kelsey.
It's about two doctors who start with
that phrase, something's not right here,
and ended up going on a crazy adventure
after a cure for a deadly disease,
which is that pancreatic
cancer. Oh, that's not good.
It is like the most deadly cancer.
This is the one that people
have nightmares about.
Why you mean it's deadly?
How like, well, it's, it's rare, but
it's deadly. It's the one where you know,
you, something's wrong. You
go to the doctor and they say,
you have six months to live. Wow. Is
it that fast? It usually is that fast.
How'd you find this out? I found this
out because my friend Amy, um, said,
I've got a friend named Dr.
Terry Brenton [inaudible].
She made a big scientific
discovery and yeah,
you should go to her press conference.
This will be amazing. Like,
go and I go to the press, male friends.
It's just a tremendous
pleasure to be here today.
Press conferences are kind
of never amazing and I hope
to one unfold a story for
you. I hope it will
capture your attention.
It's a fascinating story and I heard
this incredible story about 10 years ago.
One morning, a 40 year old
guy came into my clinic,
Mr x just finishing mine,
very healthy looking,
and he comes into my clinic and he says,
I'm worried I'm going to
get pancreatic cancer,
that I'm going to get the curse in
my family. It was like, good gooby,
what are you talking about? And
he said, well, in my family,
my father got pancreatic cancer,
my grandfather and my foreign
uncles and my three cousins. Wow.
Four uncles, three cousins, father,
grandfather, all die of pancreatic cancer.
And this guy was sure he was next in line,
his uncles and his father looked like
the healthiest people in the world.
Six months later they're
dead. He was terrified.
He came to me is a act of desperation.
I mean, it's not a feeling, I guess
they're not. Maybe I know or you know.
But what happened when you
walked in as like Terry,
she knew exactly how he felt.
You can't even process anything.
You're just like almost in a trance.
She'd gone through that before
completely and utterly alone.
She was diagnosed with breast cancer
when she was 34 it's a sense of falling.
It's truly a sense of falling.
The world slides away from you.
You literally, it's almost like
it disappears from underneath you.
When she got the news, the first thing
her doctor did, he was a friend of hers,
pulled out the whiskey
and put it on the table.
She had a shot, which was like,
thank God he did that. [inaudible]
he said, I'm not gonna [inaudible].
We're going to fight this
thing. You are not alone.
That's all I needed to hear.
And so when she was sitting
there with with patient x,
she knew exactly what to say.
You have to step forward.
You can't step back and just [inaudible]
[inaudible]
I was young then and so I felt, look,
I fixed this thing. I'll
take that on. I can help you.
I don't care how horrible
it's what happens next.
So Terry runs back to her office and
office. She shares with another doctor,
Mary Bronner, Mary Brunner, I'm a
pathologist. So I was like, Mary,
Mary says you won't believe
this, this guy, Mr x,
walk into my office and he has this
outrageous, his crazy family histories.
Horrible problem was floored.
Terry had never heard that pancreatic
cancer could be inherited and families,
they'd never heard of anything like
that. Terry comes in and she's like,
I've got to help this guy.
I have to figure out what's
making these people sick.
And Mary, I need your help. And,
and Mary, what did she say? Well,
she's a pathologist. So, and what does
it mean to be a pathologist? Well, she's,
she's the person who
physically does the diagnosis.
When your surgeon does an operation on
you or your internist takes a biopsy of
you,
they send that tissue to me and I make
it into glass slides to look at under the
microscopes. So she spends
her time looking at tiny
pieces of Terry's patients,
smeared on little slots.
I love the emotional distance that you
have in pathology. You're, you know,
a step removed from the misery and it
makes it so much easier for me to handle
it. Does she interact with
patients? Almost never.
Terry was right up against in misery and
she was just relaying the story to me.
But I can sit very comfortably at my
microscope and be very objective and just
look at the tissue and decide where the
cancer is because I don't know these
patients. So you're
like, I gotta go do this.
Come with me as she usually
does. How did you decide that
Mary should join you? She's
my science partner. That's it.
And I have to in the cat, I usually,
so they decided in order to help this guy,
they need to go to where his family is.
He drove across the mountains
of Washington state.
[inaudible] track. They went, wanted to
get the family together. Three exactly.
Nicknames, draw their blood,
look at their blood to see if there's
something in there that's making all these
people sick. And
we arrive at the little tiny
town in eastern Washington,
a little town called Elma. And then
they didn't even have, they're so small,
they don't have a single medical facility.
So in order to do the blood draw,
we basically had to use the
subway sandwich shop in town.
Why? Why subway would
have great sandwiches.
One of the family members worked
there and asked the boss if,
if the family could all come and these
doctors could come and draw their blood
and could we use the
shop as the meeting place
walking in and thinking this is small.
So we've set up a little corner booth
with our box of blood drawing supplies and
they sort of came in waves,
uncles, cousins, nieces,
nephews and they brought their kids
filled that subway sandwich shop.
How many in all?
About 30 it was funny cause they
hadn't seen each other or like,
oh my God, see you in 10 years.
It's like wow, you guys only
live like five miles up there.
We'd bring them over to our little tiny
booth and we'd introduce ourselves.
I'm Carrie Brenton or Mary Brian or
GI doctor. I am a surgical oncologist.
The purpose of our work today is that we
are trying to find the cancer gene that
causes the disease in your family.
With your permission today, we'd
like to take a small blood sample.
It's about the size of two tablespoons.
You will not get any results
back from this blood test.
I want to be really clear about that.
It's all for us to try and find the gene.
I can't even promise that.
We'll definitely find that gene.
Here is your sandwich and
now me have some blood.
As we were waiting for most
of the family to show up,
Terry and I were sitting in this one booth
with one of the family members who we
had already identified as having
the disease. He was young,
he was in his thirties and all I could
think was you have a time bomb inside
your body.
[inaudible]
and then this little boy comes
running into the subway sandwich shop,
just like friends up to this
guy that we're talking to,
this patient to family ex. Well, his,
his arms around his daddy's
neck and kisses him and, and,
and all I could think was, oh my
God, this beautiful little child,
he has 50% chance of having
this hideous disease.
And I was so upset about that.
I was just so torn apart inside,
but I couldn't really, you know,
start over
bawling right there. Rest your head.
That wouldn't have been professional.
I held it together until
we were driving home and,
and I was telling Terry how sad I was
about that little boy and how it just
really hit me. And she said, oh,
hello. Don't worry
about him. He's adopted.
You have to remember, Mary doesn't come
face to face with patients very often.
It's not something a pathologist
does very frequently.
Pathologists have the,
I don't even know if I want to tell
you this is sort of like [inaudible]
the black side of pathology,
black humor to get you
through or whatever. Yeah.
Really black humor, you know,
we'll see things like, um,
somebody better tell this patient not
to buy the big tube of toothpaste.
Terry's laughing,
but that's why we do it
because it's so horrible.
I spent an afternoon with
Mary going through slides,
looking at pancreatic tissue, three
trying to figure out like, you know,
if this person has cancer
or not. Dozens of patients.
Now this is another case with
it. Terrible, terrible case.
And that's when I really kind of
got it. Like why she'd want to
keep herself distant. Oh, this cancer
is even worse than the last one.
This person,
if they can go to a beautiful place
on planet earth and just stay there
till it's over, we would have
enough to subway though. I mean,
were they able to, you know, figure
out what's causing this thing? Well,
once they got the blood, they worked
on it for about five years, five years.
You know, they went
chromosome by chromosome,
collaborated with all these other
researchers and at the end of the day they
discovered that the thing that causes
familial pancreatic cancer comes down to a
mistake. One little mistake on one,
one molecule molecule. I know it
comes down to one tiny molecule. Yes.
So our discovery is, uh,
we're titling it Paladin mutation causes
familial pancreatic cancer and suggests
a new cancer mechanism.
So they write a paper,
I have a press conference of all I
want to acknowledge and they celebrate.
So in the end, do they, do they
find a cure? Well, no, not yet.
They're working on, can they at least,
um, test for it now? Well, they can test,
but you know,
most pancreatic cancer
isn't hereditary like this.
This is actually a small subset.
Do Girl.
So where does that leave Mary and
Terry? I mean, where are they now?
Mary's really, yeah,
glad the research phase
is over and that she doesn't have
to be with patients anymore. Terri
nodes, they have more work to do
and they can't really give up,
but she's really tired and
thinks about it a lot. You know,
the stakes are so high in this eye.
Sometimes it's almost unbearable.
Sometimes I think I should
quit. Really? Yeah, totally.
I've talked to Mary about it,
but you know what? I know she'll,
I never stopped doing it. Right. Terry
[inaudible]
sometimes it's just too much
too.
Mary and I love to garden.
So sometimes you know,
we think about being
landscape architects. Yeah.
And then the worst thing that does is,
oh, I killed the bush. They were like,
you lose, you killed the bush.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
thanks to the little Kelsey
for reporting that story.
The next story concerns
a dad and his little boy.
There's something about this
little boy that is not quite right,
but there's something about the
dad that doesn't want to say. So
that's coming up in about a minute.
I'm Jabu Rod and I'm Robert
Krulwich Radiolab. We'll continue.
Radio lab is funded in part by
the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
the corporation for public broadcasting
and the National Science Foundation.
Hey, I'm Jana. Boom Ryan.
I'm Robert Krulwich Radiolab.
This hour our topic is diagnosis.
This next story begins with a dad,
two sons and a question. What do you
do when you notice somebody different?
I heard it from reporter Gregory, right?
Hello. Hi Gregory. Found it very
rewarding. It's nice to meet.
Nice to meet you in case. Just so
you know, it took me over a year.
You can sit down and you've to finally
get an interview with Byron France.
I'm wondering if the air,
I can turn the dead in their storage
yard and I'm up in his apartment in the
South Bronx. You'll have to skills all
of this loose paperwork. Are you just,
are you moving out or are you
moving? It looks like look like that.
Was that messy. I don't
want boxes everywhere.
Crazy piles of stuff. Okay, let
go. Don't worry about a sure.
Yeah. Sorry. Already seen it up. It's
in disarray. So who is this guy? I A,
I am a retired electrical engineer. He
worked for subway most of his life now.
Uh, I consider myself a science
researcher and it's 71 years old.
He's basically teaching
himself onto physics.
That's what all the books and stuff
you see around. I love that stuff.
And he's written this
book called Einstein's era
criticizing special relativity.
Einstein. I sent it to the New York
Academy of Science at Caltech, MIT,
Harvard, even Hawkins. Still
waiting for him to get back.
Most people just ignore him.
These are the rabies off maniac.
But then he points to his letter on the
wall. Yeah. From Neil degrasse Tyson.
They know that name, this
major scientist? Yes.
Ahead of the Hayden Planetarium in
Manhattan. Exactly. Yeah. And it says how
there you, you're just an engineer. Yeah.
Ah,
and he's BV. Why, why
do you smile when, when,
when you talk about that letter from
Neil degrasse Tyson because they know how
foolish it is. Einstein,
they didn't even want to read his paper.
He said, who is this guy up? Scott.
He just a patent
examination clerk. And Bern.
Byron founders is a man who's
proud to go against the grain.
The what other people
do. I don't really do.
And that's especially true with how he
raised his son. So now, uh, Gregory,
you're going to do, uh, some kind of a
story on he manuals. Youngest son, right?
Emmanuel. Okay.
And that's why I'm here focusing on two
to question him about how he raised his
son. Alright, that'd be glad to.
Okay, great. So here's the manual.
Hi, I'm Emmanuel [inaudible]. A man,
could you take a drink of water for me?
Just okay, thank you.
No, don't take me. Yeah,
take as many drinks of water if you want.
He's 28 so what things are
you good at? Manual, um,
writing essays and making sure
they aren't grammatically correct.
[inaudible] bowling and so
you can hear analyzing stuff.
There is something going
on with them. Um, and,
and, and not talking that much.
Yes. No. If you ask dad,
he'll say, Emmanuel's an
excellent student. Our Future,
no balance is going to win a
Nobel prize. You never know. But
if you ask Blair, I'm Blair frown or
who's that Emmanuel's half-brother.
I'm about 20 years old. And then Emmanuel,
he'll tell you that even as a little
kid, very little, five years old,
there was something odd and I
just didn't know what it was.
It's a bunch of little things.
Yeah. Like he'd look at you really weird,
kind of like a Dow face expression.
He could stare at me without blinking
for 15 minutes at a time and I would
notice, cause you didn't blink
once then there was a speech.
I did not talk as much as other people.
There was something going on with the
manual, but I did not have a word for it.
And so I'm
pushed several times
to get speech therapy,
but every time he did, dad
would just say, are you kidding?
He may have troubled stumbling and
stammering, but he'll grow out of it.
I started to layer, you
also started Einstein.
He didn't speak a word until he was
six. He was considered retarded school.
He would say that this was some, a
temporary problem that would pass.
I didn't see anything that was, that
was screaming out for attention.
He was doing his work. He
was interested in the next,
we would go out endlessly in cold weather
to the park and it seemed like things
were okay. What about Emmanuel?
Well,
I knew then I was a nicer
person and nicer person.
Yay.
And then I was sent [inaudible].
I don't automatically look
at people in the eyes,
the face and stuff, you know?
So as long as Emmanuel was a little
kid, it wasn't such a big deal.
But then he got older,
he was around 10 years old and it was,
I think at the point where I'm on,
the people would point it
out. What did they say? Well,
I have been called, um,
returning an idiot savant,
the n word and stuff.
They lost the innocence
of the elementary school.
Emmanuel would come home with bruises
on his arms. Yeah. Yeah. It was,
it was something that I constantly
thought about and worried about.
I said, yeah,
well it'd be really good for him
to get professional help with that.
Did you ask dad? He said the
problem wasn't a manual. No,
it was all the other people.
The bully. See, uh, the group
in this neighborhood, it was hot.
There was fighting constant fighting
right down the street over here.
People involved with crack.
These are big guys. You know,
I felt that it could have been a
dangerous situation. So his solution,
I decided that I wanted to teach you
manual homeschool was just to pull his son
out of school.
Yeah. And how do you feel about
this at the time? Well, I,
I really didn't know.
Oh, up here. So we're
looking in the closet here.
I thought that whatever way
he is kind of turned in.
This is a binder from one of his classes
that if he got bullied and tormented
and going to school, that it
would turn him further in. Oh,
let's see what this did. If he were here,
he could develop along his own line
until he became old enough that they
wouldn't want to pick on him. Oh,
look what we turned to nature.
Nurture. It was a big deal for dad.
You hadn't homeschooled
anybody else before, right? No.
I had to get books. I had to go
meet the principal. He left his job,
submitted a curriculum to the school and
I had to register with the state of New
York, created this syllabus
for his son, great.
10 integrated math courses and they would
wake up each morning rational numbers,
geometry, do their lessons. He's trying
to leak lateral, trying have some lunch.
This is the work that he did at home
and in the afternoon they'd go bowling.
Bowling.
The manual was an
awesome book. [inaudible]
his dad would videotape them.
Today is Tuesday, December
28 1993. It's weird footage.
It's weird to watch because the manual
is such an incredibly good boulder.
Yeah, he took it out but beautiful
shot. He's always by himself.
Tape after tape of nothing but a
manual. Nobody else in the picture
I would fan to size about throwing an
into and winning some times and stuff.
Did you think about
joining any youth league?
Well,
well I vaguely dawn about it but um,
but for some reason my dad um,
did not want me to
[inaudible].
Meanwhile his brother is just players
in Canada at a distance. Yeah.
He followed a girl there and one
day he picks a book off the shelf,
the DSM and the DSM is the a
diagdiagnosis statistical manual of mental
disorders and I started just to do,
I guess what a lot of people would do
who could get a hold of this thing is to
start diagnosing all of their friends.
I diagnosed my girlfriend and I diagnosed
my dad and then I saw her right there
on the page.
Marc's impairment in the use of multiple
nonverbal behaviors such as eye to eye
gaze, repetitive behavior patterns,
problem seeking, new friends, problem,
being able to understand what someone
must be thinking. Problems. Okay.
Went down this whole list and everything
seemed to fit Martin Pyramids and I,
I gave this promise every
time he tried to call his dad.
What do you think his dad would
say? Just stop whining. Let go.
He'll just go through
this and he shot him out.
Or you basically cut
communication? I know my son,
he would always tell me.
Then whenever I hand would
go way when I was in adult.
What does an adult mean?
Does that mean 1820 maybe 20 lesson.
Okay,
so you thought as soon as I reached
the age of 20 then I won't have these
problems. Yeah.
So did you wake up on your 20th birthday
and think I thought they made me,
things would change right away.
Okay.
But they didn't, after that,
Emmanuel says he got really depressed
and
that's how things might've stayed
until
dad had a heart attack.
Blair comes to the hospital,
finds dead unconscious in the bed,
and he realizes this is my big chance
because he was not in a position to
intervene. And you're thinking,
I'm thinking the first thing that's going
to happen is that we're going to get a
diagnosis because we're waiting
for it for so many years,
26 or older or whatever. He goes
like 25 means he's going to get help.
You know, he's, he has
to go, here's the, okay,
2005 so where are we coming into now
we're at 42nd street times square
time square is one of Emanuel's favorite
areas to hang out and I figured I
wanted to be on his
surf so they're outside.
The crowd is just beginning to arrive.
It was starting to snow a little
bit and rain some too. Yeah.
Blair turns to me and he says, oh,
have you ever heard of [inaudible]
[inaudible]
autism? I said,
I highly suspect that you have some form
of autism and I want us to find some
way for you to get a diagnosis.
[inaudible]
oh, and I said six. Don't read
the word of this to death.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
Dr. How do I pronounce your
name? FDIC. Yeah. And agnostic.
And pretty soon after new years,
oh, and where are you from?
Manual gets his diagnosis. He
goes right here on this couch.
I did get a feeling from my beginning of
the direction that he was going to meet
criteria for autism. And a month
later she told me did. I was on the
autistic spectrum. It was official,
um, k football, even Maria, uh,
good.
And so at the age of 26, finally Maria,
he, his life completely changed.
So I gave him a tape recorder to
record his life. Hello with me venue.
He's meeting with the speech pathologist
a couple of hours a week also.
He's joined this program. I know tastings.
Started making friends. Oh, do I say
hello? Hey Jason. Peace
out. Got a girlfriend.
Hey, it's me, Emmanuel once again.
And there's one lady that I
haven't talked about your name,
Norma.
And we went to central park and
we took pitches and it was great.
But I want you to say,
I thought that people who are
diagnosed with autism don't this,
the definition is they
don't want to socialize.
Well ms not because I don't do want
to buy [inaudible] this is hard to do.
He know. But here's the thing about a
manual. He's had this whole new life.
He hasn't told dad about any
of it. Hello? Anything. Not
the girl, the friends, the diagnosis.
His Dad doesn't know anything's different.
So how long have you
been keeping it a secret?
Uh, it's been since 2005. Right? Yeah.
So basically for the last two years I
manual has been leading this double life
outside. He's a person with autism,
then he comes home. Nothing's wrong.
Why [inaudible]
well, um, just the
fainting, the, anyone, um,
really, um, believe in,
but he knows he's got to tell
his dad who he really is.
Do and he keeps saying he will. Yeah,
I'm say within a month
soon. I'm not quite sure.
We can, I am a little bit
nervous about telling him
maybe within a few minutes, assuming,
let me tell him in like two weeks or so.
Another day, a mind telling method.
I mean Blair [inaudible] well
tomorrow maybe one or no.
Yeah, maybe I'm just thinking about it a
little bit too much. I don't know. Men.
Finally one night I
just want to saying that I told
him and about my diagnosis,
um,
I said I really have something
important to say and don't get angry.
And then I told him that I was diagnosed
with Asperger's syndrome and he asked
me what it was and then I told
them it is high functioning autism.
Uh, I was shocked.
That would, that would
be a good way to put it.
So do you think he has Asperger's? Yes.
Yes I do.
Okay.
When I look at this syndrome
for a lot of good parts of it,
it's e manual,
but I never at any point felt that
that Emmanuel was in need of any deep
psychological or psych psychiatric help.
But
you mean what makes you
qualified to say that?
Just being a loving parent
as I'm talking to him.
We're sitting there on the couch
in front of us on the coffee table,
is all of the manuals, notebooks
from age five onwards and they're,
they're really good stuff. I mean it's,
it's stuff that you and I would
write and he saved it all.
But the question that I feel like I
gotta ask her and I just have one more
question on my list if I
can ask you that one is, um,
now that you know that there is
something wrong with your son,
that there always was this
disorder, that it's incurable.
Do you think you did
the right thing? So d,
do you wish that he had gotten
the diagnosis earlier? No,
because I think that he's better
off at this point in time.
Why wouldn't it make a difference to
know earlier what's why you're acting.
So I
didn't want you manual to get a
diagnosis that would put him in a box,
like a label. And then dad
says to me, remember, look,
I mean if I let the school give
him some kind of diagnosis,
they would have thrown him in special
ed and say, oh, he's a retard. Look,
he can't even talk. I mean, that
would have destroyed them. Do what?
Cause irreparable damage.
I asked the doctor,
was there any truth to that? If
a manual was put into special Ed,
hypothetically, he wasn't a
district's. If the five class,
the technical word for special ed would
not have raised his academic potential.
He, he said graduate from Saint
John's with a degree in psychology.
Kids who graduated district 75 don't do
that. Just to put that in perspective,
Emmanuel comes from a neighborhood where
about 10% of the kids ever graduate
college, and my GPA was
like 3.4 and change.
Wow. And he's got Asperger's. So
now we're kind of in the opposite.
We're kind of vindicating really
what his father did. Right. Well,
in terms of his academic achievement,
his father did the right thing.
The problem with his dad's choice and
he had no way of knowing at the time was
the lack of peer groups
with teammates down.
It seems like a cruel
choice, but with choice.
So if you were your father and you
were raising your kid at that time,
would you have made
the same choice he did?
Uh, well con, well,
if I had known what I known now,
then maybe I would have maybe
back to him a little more for me.
You get to interact with
others who were like, I am,
who are like, I am
[inaudible] [inaudible]
that story from our correspondent
Gregory Warner creeks are pointing,
was made possible in part by the Roslyn
Carter Fellowship for Mental Health
Journalism.
Thanks to them and thank you to Lulu
Miller for producing that piece.
We will continue in a month.
This is Bonnie calling
from Boston, Massachusetts.
Radiolab is supported in part by the
National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hello, I'm Jad Boom Ron and
I'm Robert Krulwich. Radiolab.
This hour we're going to talking about
diagnosis, diagnosis, the easy kind.
We're not going to talk about it.
Easy would be you come into my office
and I'm a doctor. You have a broken arm.
I take a picture. I say, Hey, you've
got a broken arm. The picture says so.
Yeah. Cause you can see
the break right there.
But let's suppose you came
into my office and you sad.
You tell me that your sex drive is down.
Yay. I'm the doctors who are gonna sit.
But just between you
and me. All right. Well,
right away my learning tells me that
you may be a candidate for depression,
but how do I know that you're
depressed? What do you mean?
How do we know we talk
about it? You just said,
well you can't measure
sadness or depression.
You can't go to a test tube
and count anything. Right.
It's not hard science.
Yeah, because till now,
what if I put you in, you know,
one of those FMR try machines that
we've talked about so often? Yeah.
I snap a picture of your brain in action
and I look at it and from your picture
I say that you are depressed. You're
going to tell me I'm depressed.
Just from looking at a picture
of my brain. Yes, no way. Look,
it's now here. Photographic diagnosis
of mental illness is happening.
There is no question and that by the
way is Eric Candela professor up at
Columbia University who just happens to
have won the Nobel prize for medicine.
Let me give you a little historical
background. Did you get a note? Oh,
I don't think you did. I
still don't believe you.
And what just cause he's got a Nobel
prize. I'm going to suddenly turn it on.
You're not. So let's do this
step by step. Okay. Step one.
Imagine you're slipping
into an FMRI machine. Okay.
Right now I want you to just look at
my face. Why is that so difficult?
I just wanna where this is
going anywhere here. Okay.
I'm looking at your face now
that you're looking at my face,
different regions of the
brain, they become active.
There are cells in your brain
that are saying, I know him.
The cells are more active. They
need energy. Just like when you run,
you have to breathe fast and to get the
energy, your heart pumps more blood.
The body sends a rush of fresh blood
with that particular group of cells and
because the blood has iron in it,
the magnet and the brain scanner can
see the iron and therefore see the blood
flow and take pictures of it. Many,
many pictures in real time. I'll
show you a very nice example of this.
Eric's now heading off across his ample
office with an extraordinary view of the
Hudson Valley and he brought over a
picture of a human brain with different
colors in different areas, and he
told me, when you look at a face,
when you image the face,
this area lights up.
You're pointing to an area of
the gray area of the brain.
You're on your forehead kind
of. That's right. That's right.
If you look at a house,
some other area lights up,
but this area does not light
up. You look at another face.
This area lights up again every time
you see a face, the same area. Yup.
But you haven't told me anything
about emotions yet. That's true.
So let's move on to step two
because we use faces to tell what someone
else is thinking or someone else's
feeling.
Looking at faces also triggers an area
deep in the brain that is concerned with
emotion called the Amygdala.
Now very recently number of people have
at the make the looking at faces and
it's extremely interesting. Step three.
Okay, I'm going to take you now to
London. Hello. Hi. Yeah, hi. Yeah,
that's good. It's [inaudible] who's
this? Oh wait, sorry. Who are you?
I'm Cynthia [inaudible]. My psychiatrist
at the Institute of Psychiatry.
King's college. London.
And Are you liking your thirties or your
forties or fifties this is part of the
interview I want cause like,
cause I wanted to establish that she
came into psychiatry. Trying to think,
when did I graduate medical school.
I didn't have very critical time.
I finished my training in 97 I training
psychiatry in 97 that's 1997 when the
Fmri machines were first
becoming available.
And so Cynthia was able to do a rather
amazing study what in this study she got
together a group of people who were
clinically depressed, depressed people,
and then another group of people who are
normal healthy people and she put them
in the brain scan machine and
showed them facial expressions,
thesis ranging from more neutral
expressions to more sad expressions.
So they saw a sad face and then a
neutral face and then a sad face.
That's right.
And what the person in the machine was
supposed to do is look at these faces and
decide whether it was a
man or a woman's face.
What does that have to do
with anything? Because,
because while they were doing that,
how they're making the decision,
the emotion of the face is
being processed automatically.
The amygdala sees the emotion on the
faces at that moment and the machine,
it's like tick, tick, tick, tick, tick.
And they were hundreds of pictures.
10th of a second to 10th of a second.
A 10th of a second. That's right.
Did you see a difference between the
people who were depressed and the people
who were normal? Yes.
Was it a significant difference or just
barely difference as a group it was a
significant difference and
now she takes the big step.
Step four from the pattern
she sees in bunches of people,
she feeds all those patterns into
a computer called machine learning,
told the program. This is a pattern
of brain activity and depress people.
This is a pattern of brain
activity in healthy people.
And then she shows the computer
a brain scan of a new person.
So this is someone in the computers
never met before. Exactly.
And she did this a bunch of time,
right? A whole bunch of people
and each time the computer tries to get,
is this new person depressed
or not? Oh and and what?
What happened? More than 85% of the time,
86% of the time the algorithm correctly
diagnosed whether that person was
depressed or healthy
[inaudible]
with just a brain scan,
a computer and a patient.
No doctor needed Cynthia's
computer got the diagnosis right.
[inaudible]
6% of the time a computer. We saw the
results. I was like, wow, this is amazing.
Wait a second. Has she
repeated this? Well,
this is actually the very first time that
this has been done with depression and
so it was
just a pilot study and like you say,
someone else will have to do
it again and again and again,
but according to Cynthia
potentials, fantastic.
Psychiatry is going to be
absolutely revolutionized by this.
I think this method can be applied
to any psychiatric disorder,
any autism. It's a Freeney obsessive
compulsive disorder. No Way. Come on.
Why not?
Every one of these illnesses ultimately
must have an anatomical basis,
every one of these illnesses,
so this means that it will soon or one
day be possible for a patient to come in
and you take a picture of him in real
time or of her and you will have a
diagnostic tool. That's what
you're saying? Absolutely.
Absolutely.
You mean to tell me that they're going
to put people in machines and just go
boom, no, no, wait, wait, wait.
This is not a casual thing.
You go to the doctor,
you tell the doctor that
you're feeling a certain way.
The doctor will talk to you and
then he would come to you and say,
well my learning and the test
tells me that you're ill.
So that's all it's happening here is now
the medical doctor was out at habitats.
We haven't, there's nothing in
this that feels invasive to you.
Well obviously huddling into the deep
depths of your personhood. No, this is,
if you believe that mental
illness is a mental illness,
it is a structural condition
which can be fixed.
So it's not the deep inner
you, it's the broken you.
So it's like the broken arm.
You started off with it that c you would
put the two side by side think I would.
And then of course you get
to the next, come on rubber.
I mean human beings are
way too messy for that.
You're too messy for it to
be that easy. No, no way.
So you think this is out of science's
reach? Really? It's just too,
there's a part of me that does
think it is out of science.
Because you think you think that
they're looking deep inside you.
That's what you don't like. I
do. I mean, don't get me wrong,
I find brain scans fascinating when it
comes to questions like where is the
soul? Where does consciousness,
that kind of stuff,
but don't kind of get in my head and
tell me what's what's right and what's
wrong. Sad and sick. Don't
you want to get better? Yes,
but I enjoy the comfortable ambiguity
that would come from a situation like
sitting in a therapist office and
saying, well, I'm, how am I feeling?
I'm feeling this way or that way and in
the messiness of trying to just rely on
how you're feeling, there's a vast
landscape of of things that can happen.
Choices. You can make, therapies
you can pursue this way.
Let's say you are sick and you know
that you're sick machine or no. Okay.
[inaudible] if you are feeling badly,
wouldn't it be nice if a machine could
help you find the right kind of help?
What do you mean? Well, Eric took me
through a little thought experiment,
a mind experiment.
You've developed a psychotherapy
and I've developed a psychotherapy.
We each claim it's the best in the world.
Now we have an objective way of seeing
this machine allows you to independently
of any evaluation,
see the outcome of treatment
and so you can audit the doctor,
audit the doctor and give you evidence
that it's working or no. Okay.
Yeah, a little bit on board. I G I
can give you 10% buy in now. Okay,
so how far off is this stuff?
Is it going to come soon?
This is very early in the game obviously,
but I get ask him like how far into
the future are we talking about here?
Soon or mid after long after you're dead.
I'm going to be around a lot,
but the question stands,
will you make it to see that
that people will actually have a,
you don't want can't in
medicine in all honesty,
give a timeline for many of these things.
Can imaging methodology right now is
quite sophisticated but it's still
primitive compared with needs to be.
You're picking this up in
status in this ascending.
You become excited as the
thing is beginning to emerge.
We see it for the first
time on the horizon.
You saying we've got to the story
too early. That's what you're saying,
just right. It's not going to be
interesting. 20 years from now,
it'll be obvious.
Or in 20 years it'll be obvious
that we were wrong. Okay.
That's a real possibility because what
we don't know is alive. Vast. Yeah.
And a, I want to tell you a story now
about just how wrong people can be. Okay.
It begins with a mystery,
sudden infant death syndrome,
perfectly healthy child goes to
sleep and dies during the night.
[inaudible]
it's about the worst thing
that can happen to a parent.
And each year it does happen about 7,000
times. It's still, no one knows why.
Oh, and by the way, that
was Robert Sapolsky.
He's a professor of neuroscience
at Stanford University,
and the Spolsky tells this story of the
moment sids was diagnosed for the first
time,
or at least classified in a terrible
mistake that was made around 1900 or so.
People were being made to recognize
this as a disease entity and nobody knew
what was up. So people decided,
let's go dissect sid skids.
Meaning when a baby would die, they
would perform an autopsy. Exactly, yes.
Checked the baby's inside.
See if there's anything different in them
from normal kids. That seems logical.
Absolutely.
They measure the size of the
baby's lungs. Yep. Normal.
They measured the size of the heart.
Yep. Nothing strange there. Stomach,
kidney, liver. Yep. Those are all fine.
Then they would look in the throat.
[inaudible]
they look in there and they
say, oh my God, these sids kids,
they have enormous famous
glance. The thymus of famous.
What is the famous, what is wonder? Well,
it is a little tiny pink
gland that is right.
Your player red beyond
your color though, Huh?
At the base of your throat and its job
is to help you fight disease makes one
type of cell critical
to your immune system,
especially in times of stress. Any case,
normally this little organ is about
the size of a tiny tube of toothpaste,
like the tribal coin, but in these
six kids it was huge. MongoDB,
enormous. Twice size. Exactly.
And since the thymus is
dangerously close to the windpipe,
doctors came up with a hypothesis,
perfectly reasonable hypothesis,
which was that maybe if you're one of
these babies with an enlarged thymus and
you're asleep and somehow you roll over
wrong [inaudible] well that gland might
press down on your trachea and
suffocate you during the night. Oh, so
medical mystery solved. Really? No,
they even came up with a name for it.
It was called status find
mackolen phatic in the spoons.
It was an all the pediatric textbooks
by the 1920s and you would look in there
and there'd be pictures.
There would be pictures of the dissector
fine mrs normal size and here on the
right in large abnormally large
status find the colon fat.
And in no time at all, doctors
came up with a treatment,
perfectly logical therapy, which is that
if we're going to help these babies,
we've got to shrink their
thymus gland. And to do that,
the best solution obviously is to
irradiate their throats or radiate their
throats to shrink their thymus gland.
Come on
the child's throat with trillions
of radioactive particles.
You literally, you Betcha.
And this was considered like something
every good loving parents should do.
Absolutely. If you worry about
your child being at risk for sids,
go and get their throats irradiated to
shrink the thymus gland and did it work?
Yes. Shrank the thymus gland. But
he says it did have another effect.
Decades later. You've killed 20 to
30,000 people with thyroid cancer.
[inaudible]
20 30,000 deaths. That's a, that's
a real number. Yeah, that's a,
that's a fairly big one.
So here's my question.
How could these doctors have
gotten it so, so, so, so, so wrong.
Do you know what I mean? Yeah, I
do. I don't. You know what you mean?
You just answered your own question
a minute ago. No, no, I didn't.
I'm about to answer it right now.
They're, they're playing with radiation.
You just said that. But what they, what?
They didn't know that radiation would
hurt you. They had no, it was like,
that's not technology, but
that's not what I was going to
[inaudible].
This was, you know, a couple of decades
into radiation having been discovered.
I could cope, start performing near
miracles of diagnosis and discovery.
People were just tossing around
radiation all over the place.
Iodine one 31 radioactive sodium right
off gamma rays neutron and this was a
period with madame Curie dipping
her arm into vats of uranium.
Radioactivity is harmless in
dying. Soon afterwards from cancer,
people who would go into shoe stores
and they would have their feet. Yes,
x ray is a wonderful invention.
I had that. You had that.
I did naturally take off your shoes
and you can look at your balloons.
That's exactly what that, how
would you do? That's what that was.
That was the thing you could do at the
shoe store. It was very cool. Yeah.
Showing how cutting edge of a
shoe store or they aren't yet
[inaudible]
your explanation. No, that
may look like the explanation.
I made sure every radiation, we
played a role, but if you would have,
let me say what I was going to say, I
would have told you the real explanation.
Yes. Preceded the radiation by
like a couple hundred years. Hello?
I don't no idea what you're talking.
I'm going to tell you back in the
17 hundreds okay. That far back,
that far back before radiation,
before your grandpa four, uh,
before the civil war or the
Eiffel tower or Napoleon,
I'm talking when the red coats
were still wearing red. Yeah. Yeah.
This was shortly after the revolutionary
war. Right about this time says,
supposedly the first med schools started
to pop up in America and a supply and
demand issue came into effect because
with these med schools came med students,
all students who needed to learn about
anatomy and of course in order to do
that, they needed bodies, you know,
to dissect this produced
this whole occupation.
You could be a resurrection
or resurrect Shanice. Yup.
And they would go out and dig
up bodies that's at night.
Then sell them to the anatomist
as the medical schools.
I'll need two more by Thursday. Dang. Now,
here's the key points.
Since demand was so high,
the resurrection just had to go
where the bodies were easiest to get,
which meant, you know,
avoiding the fancy graveyards.
If you were wealthy,
you could have yourself buried in
what was called a patent coffin,
which was a tripled way or coffin, which
was meant to be resurrection as proof.
But if you are not wealthy,
no fancy coffin for you,
you'd probably just be buried
in a sack in some poppers field,
just a few inches under the soil.
Very accessible for these
resurrection lists. Not surprisingly,
that's where they weren't
always telling the same topic.
Are you explaining why children
died there? Me. Alright.
What I'm trying to make is that the grave
robbers targeted the poor so much so
it's sometimes when they, you know,
people would catch these resurrection
that's in the act and see like, oh my God,
that's my dad. You're
digging up. There'd be riots.
Stop stealing off treats.
We're called out and wires were shot.
Are we talking like hundreds of people?
Torch bearing was townies versus the
people you were trying to dissect their
dead relatives. This
is a lot of history. I'm
very fascinated in quotes.
What does this have to do with kids dying
of fire? Right? Let me bring it home.
Not that it hasn't been interesting,
but bring it home. Okay.
As a result of all of this hubbub over
a grave robbing country after country
Europe decided, no, let's standardize
how science gets it's cadavers.
Forget all this grave robbing.
So they passed laws which formalized
anyone who died in a poor house,
a, their body would be turned
over to the anatomists.
This was like the cadaver version
of direct deposit. Okay, so great.
Robyn was gone, but now all the bodies
used by medicine and not just some,
but nearly all now came from the poor
estimates were by the end of that century,
99% of the body's used for,
for anatomy lessons had been derived from
poor houses and that seemed okay until
1936 a guy named Hans Lea showed that
being poor actually warps your body.
And now Robert,
now we come back to the gates of
the mysteriously enlarged thymus.
Cause if you're poor, you're
either worried about your job,
you're worried about feeding your
family, you're worried about the bills.
In other words,
you are stressed out and during chronic
stress your immune system goes down the
tubes. And since the time is
this part of the immune system,
if you are chronically stressed,
the thymus gland shrinks.
[inaudible] for 150 years, doctors
had been dissecting cadavers,
pointing at organs which
they thought were normal,
but which were in fact shrunken from a
life of poverty and stress and saying
that's normal.
So that when these sids babies show up
with these gigantic Thomas', oh my God,
in fact, that was the first time
they'd ever seen a normal one.
People had no idea what was normal
and what was abnormal and they got it
backwards.
[inaudible]
Robert Sapolsky, a professor of
neuroscience at Stanford University.
He's the author of many great
books including monkey love,
the trouble with testosterone from our
information on him or anything that you
heard in this hour. Visit our website,
radio lab.org and you can send
us an email while you're there.
radio@wnyc.org is actually is the
address. Remember that? Yup. I'm Jan.
I boomerang. I remember
Krulwich. Thanks for listening.